how you doing guys today we have a
special guest Miss Emma let's do it off
Stewart's cinnamon cafe and found out
the October Film Festival how you doing
today you actually our first guest yes
we got this amazing platform on phone
courage we just we decided to have you
okay and because this type yes this
title of this series is put your money
where your mouth for this all my money
oh yeah all the kids money all the
College Fund
this is a port in series because I
believe that people want people to
invested in yeah yeah I realize you got
investing yourself yes so tell me your
journey we made you get into this crazy
world of entertainment wow that's a
loaded question um so I you know have a
real estate background I'm really a
business person who happens to be in the
arts somebody gave me a script I read it
I thought oh I want to help this guy
tell this story I called him up I said
what do you need he said everything I
had no idea what everything was
everything was a lot of money and then I
produced it in it won some awards and I
thought wow if I could figure out how to
monetize this I could do this for a lot
of people hmm so you had the passion of
giving early on yes yes I couldn't have
said that better - yeah yeah so you
started with filmmaker they needed help
yes they won the wars cuz of you do you
guys still keep in contact yes
absolutely
what's the filmmaking name again we shut
up yes so what I want to know now is you
did that now we've made you start a
festival yeah so I went to a lot of film
festivals as you guys have and there was
just stuff that was missing I felt like
a lot of the festivals no offense to
anyone out there I love all you guys but
some of the festivals were very pullin
oh right and I felt like I wanted to
start a festival that was clean and by
that I mean a festival where it doesn't
matter who's in your film it doesn't
matter how many followers you have it's
strictly based on you being a great
filmmaker who can who can tell a
compelling story and so then I said you
know what I'm gonna start my own film
festival where we could do that where we
could just give a platform and celebrate
filmmakers for being filmmakers yeah
yeah and that's great because a lot of
fun makers out there have got done
notice a lot of festivals turn into a
business yeah they showing 300 films
taking submission fees and half the time
they really see you so one day like
about October Film Festival it's very
intimate is very engagement a teacher
festival when you start the festival do
you even realize how much I mean like
you in touch I had no idea I I still
can't really wrap my head around all of
the people that I see on television now
the awards I mean justjust even you guys
just to see all the stuff that you've
done and then I know you sometimes I see
you and I'm like ah how wonderful yeah
to my viewers that's how we met yeah I
was a regular filmmaker I submitted my
feature film life is he short yeah
someone taught and this is all about
putting your money where your mouth is
yeah so a little background story was
emblems of festival was that this poet
end date in Harlem I actually rented out
a few months before and I sold it out
packed the house multiple times
and my name stopped buzzing and she
started hearing my name and I got to a
festival and I felt like home and I go
to the big festivals you get lost
because if you don't have a big name for
your festival or big publicist you will
literally get lost in the sauce so ya
never know about networking and contact
and since then we've been doing business
and doing partnership since then yeah
that also speaks to you never know who's
watching you never know what's right
because then I looked you up and then I
was kind of just following and watching
before I called you and said not only do
I want your film in the festival but I
also would like you to come and speak to
filmmakers about how you did this thing
how did you sell out a theatre multiple
times and then I'm thinking cuz I had
never heard of you so how did he do that
no really and I thought well if he could
do it surely other people could do it we
just don't know how yeah and that's why
we're a teaching festival and I said you
know I need to have him come and talk to
filmmakers about how he did this thing
that's a lesson for the filmmakers out
there yeah put your best foot forward
all the time so now you just business
woman you got your festival you know you
help some filmmakers now you decided
almost optimal data yeah now what's
going on in that hand and like why you
wanna do this now yeah you know so and
it's and again I think that a lot of the
things that I do it's an answer to my
own problem right and so I was renting
space every year for the festival and I
felt like the venue's were treating us
badly considering that we were spending
twelve to fourteen thousand for four
days to rent a space I felt like the
venue's didn't understand filmmakers and
the importance of the Q&A so we were
rushed you know there was a year where
they turned the lights off during our
red carpet yeah yeah he was there and
and it just was devastating when a movie
doesn't play and they're like well we
got to keep moving so too bad it just
and I thought you know what this can't
continue to happen I want to be able to
control when I have the festival when
the filmmakers have events we should be
treated better and I think what what
better way to do that than to start my
own movie theater where I could give
distribution in terms of theater runs
where I could help filmmakers make money
and monetize their talent grow their
audience and then at the same time not
have to deal with venues that don't
understand what we do you know when you
go into a place where there's a four
wall they don't necessarily understand
all of the issues that filmmakers have
when you're trying to show their films
we're here at Stewart cinnamon cafe so
we had this famous move dear that you
started from the ground up tell us the
service tell us what is this we provided
for the community you know it's
interesting you called it a famous
theatre
and I heard somebody earlier this week
sort of referred to it in the same way
and I said why do you call it famous and
she said because you're the first black
latina to own your own movie theater and
have a motion picture license and all of
the stuff that comes with that and I
thought wow so people really feel like
this is a historical first and that so
that movement yeah and I think the main
reason is that you have so many theaters
out there yeah and you don't know who
the owners are like that's true and this
is a strong connection because there's
nothing like seeing your own self your
own people like wow I could do that yes
and that's I want to segue into my next
question is it is young females out
there that's wanna be will you add that
wanna produce how do you balance being a
woman in this man about me huh yes
that's it's hard I will say I had major
challenges building this place because
although the contractors and all the
business people that I dealt with to do
this they really had a hard time
listening to what I was saying I'm a
producer so I'm always looking for money
and there is this idea that we women do
not know how to manage money that were
not a good investment
2018 yeah yeah but and it's changing
right that's changing but that was also
one of the struggles I had with raising
money to do this that's because people
really felt like I didn't know what I
was talking about so I think part of it
is you've got to have a lot of your own
skin in the game especially as a woman
right because if you're going to wait
for somebody to write you a check
based on your talents and your vision it
may not happen
yeah so you have got to figure out how
to make it happen for yourself
you know I I don't need a man to
validate me
and I feel like you know we all have our
different strengths and weaknesses but I
know what I bring to the table and I
think that's critical like you have to
know what you bring to the table if
you're coming there with your two arms
swinging you you can't eat at that table
so if you know what you bring to the
table I think you have a much better
chance of making it yes until my tower
filmmakers out there you gotta bring
value your talent is just not enough no
more if you have talent that's like a
bonus yeah so if it's a table you better
bring a knife we're having the meat milk
because we in the industry now that it
just doesn't matter how talented you are
I don't think it's not about talent as
much it's knowing I mean I it matters
right matters it matters the bonus but
when you take two actors for example who
are equally good it's the one with the
hustle they get no audition yeah it's
the one that's that's sending out the
headshots that's that's you know walking
around the streets looking for work
that's the person getting the jobs and
that doesn't necessarily mean that
they're more talented it but it's that
it's that dry yeah and that's why this
series called
put your money where your mouth is
because the hustle so separate yeah I'm
a filmmaker less is the actor we both
want multiple awards it's people out
there that's better than us but what
happened is we out hustling everybody
[Laughter]
and that's you got to do now right now
if you going to meet in yeah actually I
mean it's a grant followed you got like
what yeah so it's like it becomes a
numbers game so also being a founder
owner how is it Dylan have me own kids
how is that balance like wow that's
that's tough I have always said the
hardest part of being in the business is
how many times I have to say goodbye to
my children
just in the morning and I travel a lot
and I'm gone a lot and it's hard but
I'll say this
I live in every moment that I'm in
separately so tonight I'm here with you
I'm in this moment I'm celebrating
what's happening right here when I go
home
I'm in that moment with my children I am
the mommy
I am homework I am doing all that stuff
I'll see you don't think your work home
with you it's it's one moment at a time
when I'm with my mom and we're having
coffee I'm a daughter and at that moment
that's what I do and that's a beautiful
thing you have to learn how to be
different people yeah if you're married
gotta be a husband or wife that night
yeah if you own the company gotta be a
CEO that night if you're active so you
have to play multiple hats and sometimes
confusing but what do you do to detox
the having all this with leisure DTAC
moments I read a lot okay
and and believe it or not I love reading
about the industry mm-hmm so a lot of
time do you see me posting it's I am
hungry for knowledge and the more that I
learned that happier and more fulfilled
I feel because I think there's just some
rooms that we're not gonna get invited
to yeah but I love that you share that
knowledge I'm people they think oh I'm
gonna hold on to it keeps myself I don't
want anybody else to get ahead yeah
can't get it you can't get ahead that
way you can't yeah and that's the new
actor you know in the business what do
you do to detox well usually what I like
to do like just stay at home and just
hang out with my partner hang out with
my dog and sometimes you have to
actually get away from what you do in
order to actually enjoy just couldn't
yeah exactly it's almost like you shut
down yeah and then you leave boot once
you go back into that world you have to
do that otherwise your dog is so crazy
yeah I think everybody talks me I could
travel by traveling away from everything
and I come back to refresh another
question I want to ask you is text you
when you're traveling about work all the
time well that's another game too when
you everybody have a car she was in the
middle of where were you in Dubai
I'm like texting asking questions that's
big do a lot of business together right
and then I thought wait he's in Dubai I
shouldn't be texting well that's called
a parlous ministry for you guys to know
you're gonna be people that's at the
prior beliefs that you're gonna get
right back to yeah there's gonna be
people that you see the text we won't
because it's not when they're probably
lists and that's the reality another
question how to actually see now
somebody who texts me today and didn't
hear back from me and watches this yeah
listen guys it's not fair this is what
it happens another question I want to
ask you is I'm doing all this stuff
doing this business you set yourself up
for your legacy when you're not handle
more was one thing what people say about
you she cared Wow
cuz I care yeah I really really I can't
yeah what about you Elizabeth well I
care about everybody I'm always no I
just want people to realize that I made
a difference I want people to say while
Esther was a great guy he helped me out
I remember when I needed an agent and he
got me that agent I remember when he
gave me advice on how to start my own
film
I wrote that great book right exactly
you can get that on Amazon that way I
love yourself yes but no I just that's
why I did the book because I want to
give back to the people I want people to
get something for me I don't want to
feel like I'm taking everything for
myself it's not about that yeah yeah
guys this was a triptych conversation
all the stuff that we talked about yeah
we didn't there was definitely nothing
yeah yeah just so guys this is unshifted
conversation and to an hour less degree
M on Stewart film courage we have